هذا الفريق المغربي يسير في
إقليم مجهول هنا في كأس العالم ،
لم يصل أي فريق أفريقي
إلى نصف النهائي ولم يصل أي فريق عربي
إلى نصف النهائي ، وبعد أن
وصل إلى هذا الحد ، ليس لدى أسود الأطلس أي
نية للتوقف.  الآن
قبل المباراة الحاسمة يوم الأربعاء
ضد حامل اللقب فرنسا المغرب
المدرب وليد الرجراجي وضع لاعبيه
في واحدة من التدريبات الأخيرة
في هذه البطولة وهم
يعرفون التدريبات حتى الآن ولن يمروا على
مراحل من قبل أي شخص يصطف ضدهم
بعد أن تعادل بالفعل.  ضد منتخب
كرواتيا الذي وصل إلى نهائي 2018 ، تغلبت على
بلجيكا في المرتبة الثانية ثم
تخلصت من منتخب إسبانيا والبرتغال.
هدف ضد كندا ، إنها قصة نجاح
يبدو أنها موحّدة
لقاعدة المشجعين العرب ولا يستطيع مشجعوهم
الاكتفاء منهم ولكن أكبر مشجعيهم.
هم بالتأكيد أمهاتهم الذين تم نقلهم من
قبل الاتحاد للمساعدة في توحيد الفريق
، فقد كانت ضربة تكتيكية رئيسية
أيضًا توفر بعضًا من أكثر
المشاهد التي لا تنسى في البطولة عندما
بدأ المغرب التدريب هنا الشهر الماضي
لم يكن الكثيرون يتصورون أنهم سيفعلون ذلك.
أن تكون من بين الصدارة القليلة الماضية لكنها
كانت بطولة مليئة بالمفاجآت ، لذا ربما
يكون من المنطقي تمامًا أنهم
أعزاء كأس العالم هذه وربما
أكبر مفاجأة لم تأت بعد